thank you for coming to this talk i'm
i'm pretty excited to share all of this
with you
and uh as a concern of mine just because
the amount of material that i'm trying
to tell you
let's hold questions to the end i'll
make myself available and then on the
slack
channel for this talk feel free to add
anything and i'll make sure i get to it
so
before i really get into it i just want
to acknowledge the people that made this
work possible so i work at knc a small
consulting firm
based out of los angeles
and uh
joe maglianis
was the one who funded it so big thank
you and then jeff lembacher is a
co-worker of mine and really helped with
some of the statistical work that was
done in this
as well
so what what should you expect from this
presentation well
really i want to give you intuition and
starting points so that if you find any
of this stuff in interesting you can
kind of jump uh step some of the initial
work that needs to be done just to learn
the vocabulary and learn kind of what's
going on in the field more concretely of
course it's going to be four parts
so the the problem that i'm really
fascinated with is how do we model
human movement and what i mean by that
is given a configuration of people
in an environment and each person has a
trajectory that they wish to
arrive at
how can we predict the movement of those
people in that space
so that's that's the question
i find that
any time you're kind of jumping into a
new field it's it's good to know the
history and why that that problem became
a field in itself and so what we're
going to do is kind of look at some of
the stages of crowd dynamics as a field
and to understand why
it is where it is today
maybe not surprisingly any time there's
kind of a engineering tone oftentimes
it's just practicality that drives the
the need and in this case
in the 60s a paper by fruin uh was one
of the first to actually quantify
what uh like good sidewalk design was
and he borrows from this uh a lot of the
the work that was being done in traffic
kind of sciences and highway design and
the the term that they use is level of
service so you can designate certain
kind of corridors with a level of
service based on the amount of people
that kind of comes through that space
this isn't really uh i guess
the this this concept should make sense
but
the way it was able to actually be done
is that
photography really allowed someone to
actually analyze
kind of the trajectories and the changes
that would go on and so photography was
instrumental in being able to do this
work and what you see on that right side
is kind of the the six levels of service
they're termed by a to f and that just
kind of designates the density of a
certain space with kind of what you
should expect in terms of speed or the
flow of that that kind of movement of of
people in that space with that many
people
so in the 70s
people started you know actually looking
at at crowd dynamics more closely and
they started to see resemblances of
particles in space so again i don't
think that this is a very big conceptual
jump to make but what
this paper by henderson was able to show
was that we can apply maxwell
boltzmann's kind of mechanics
and
states of gaseous
particles and say what if we make those
same assumptions about people and how
well does that correlate with sort of
data that we have and so that that's
kind of leading to more of a physical
based understanding of movement movement
and less about
the actual practicality of designing
good streets though this work is helpful
in actually analyzing whether your kind
of
streets are designed well
so then in the 90s we start getting kind
of an explosion of kind of new concepts
and this is really in part because we
now have computers to actually do some
of this simulation for us and so we can
actually encode some of these principles
and then
see do our simulations actually match uh
with the data that we have and so this
paper called the
social force model
for pedestrian dynamics is really
interesting the concept is that every
time you move around a space you're
bombarded by forces that either attract
or repulse you
to give a really clear
description of of what this is imagine
if a
wall is on fire you definitely don't
want to walk right next to it so there's
a force that's pulsing you away and the
the concept here is that acceleration
velocity and all of those actual
quantifiable metrics can be distilled
down as a submission of all of those
forces that you can attach
so pretty interesting model and uh is
still used today and and
helping uh is still working in this in
this field
so more recently though uh it's come to
kind of an understanding and i i don't
think this is surprising that no one
specific algorithm so you see social
forces as the top
left
can actually predict well the total
configuration of people in an
environment and so what this kind of
graph shows is
each point is a different configuration
of people
and the colors
blue
uh being good and red not being so great
show that no one of them is able to
capture the entire space and as a result
this this paper crowd space a predictive
crowd analytic technique is helping to
show that perhaps there are ways to
first determine what space you're in and
then apply the right algorithm to it
so
we're going to take a step and so at
this point during this this work that i
i did
i realized that i wasn't going to
actually uncover some hidden human kind
of underlying physical equation and as a
result i wanted to try to rely more on
kind of reinforcement learning to do
that so to kind of give a brief summary
of how reinforcement learning works so
of course you have this agent there in a
space and this agent is going to have an
environment
that is the space that they're in
and they're going to take an action that
action could just be taking steps
forward jumping moving around doesn't
have to just be some locomotive action
it can be something else like
you know playing a
moving a piece in a game or playing some
sort of action like that the thing to
remember too is that the agent may not
have access to the entire environment so
they may only have a sliver of kind of
what they observe we call that state so
the agent has some state that they have
access to from the environment
and then from that state they're able to
say you know was this is this a good
state for me to be in so or is it a bad
state and you attach some reward to that
the the really kind of key component
here is the policy and that's going to
tell you that given in this state that
i'm in what's my next action i should
take so a lot of academic work is
focused on on kind of the policy for
this stuff that
we've been working on it's really about
more determining the right reward which
is also very important but to kind of
break down that same loop and talk about
the key difference that reinforcement
learning has against supervised learning
is that your action influences your
environment and your environment may not
change but what's important here is that
your data that you capture will change
so in a sense that
your actions will influence
sort of the state that you get back and
as a result
that state is what's
propelling your reward
and so there's a very close link between
kind of the data you're able to to
acquire and the actions that you take
and so as a result there um is work done
to try to mitigate some of those effects
so i i'm gonna go into sort of the the
math of it and so if this uh if you're a
little less math inclined just try to
stick with me uh because i think it can
be understood and that's what my hope is
to kind of share that intuition so uh in
literature the the policy is going to be
represented as the as pi
most times they're they're sometimes
it's represented as another
symbol but let's just assume right now
and you'll most likely see it it's going
to be represented as pi the symbol right
next to pi is theta
and theta are the parameters in your
neural network that need to be adjusted
so really the the problem at hand is
find the right parameters find the right
thetas
now the kind of inside the parentheses
you have two uh items so you have a of t
so that's going to be your action and
then you have s of t
maybe not surprisingly that will be your
state of at a certain time and so what
this says is
given this state
what is the probability of taking this
action and so that that vertical bar
says that kind of given
what's the probability of the action now
it's important to remember that
initially when you start
that there's no meaning of whether this
is good probability or bad probability
and so what you need is something called
a advantage function which tells you
whether you're actually in a good state
or a bad state
whether you've taken good actions or bad
actions and so the policy itself is just
returning back probabilities of some
given state but you need this advantage
function that actually informs you
whether it's
a good or bad action and so what that
breaks down to is your past rewards
minus your expected rewards and so if
this number is positive it means that
you're doing better than you expect if
this number is negative you're doing
worse than you expect
in math this represents uh usually as a
submission
over sort of this gamma terms this
discounting term
and it's multiplied by r of t which is
your reward so you just sum that up
the the gamma is usually to to weigh
more so the gamma is used to say that
rewards that i receive today are more
valuable than rewards that i received
say 100 steps ago so that's what the
gammas they're doing and then this v is
a value function
and basically its job is just to predict
given the state that i'm in how much
reward should i get in the future
and now you might ask how do i calculate
v well v is very much a supervised
learning problem and you calculate that
after your episode so you have all your
information and you basically just try
to map the states to that final reward
that you have that's how you train v and
that gives you what your your expected
reward is
i'm going to multiply the whole thing by
log
number of reasons for this but i think
the best one is that you want your
numbers to behave nicely and anytime
you're going to be doing some sort of
optimization using gradient descent
it's important that your numbers are
well behaved and then the last thing
we're going to do is just add an
expectation operator over the whole
thing
that's basically going to say that after
a number of runs
i just want to calculate the average and
what i've just showed you right now is
called the vanilla
policy gradient
but i'm going to be a little bit more
ambitious and i'm going to try to give
you the intuition of what is actually
used
it's ppo so this is from openai
it stands for proximal policy
optimization and it's really good and
i'll tell you why and i hope to motivate
why it is good so
imagine you have your policy now again
the the thing i tried to push forward is
that your actions are going to be
influencing the amount of data that you
acquire so so the circle around this
policy is meant to represent kind of the
data that's accessible by that policy
now your new policy might have a
different distribution of data that it's
allowed access to
that area could be bad and as a result
you could end up getting stuck
and being and not being able to move
forward in kind of the learning process
and so the key thing here is we only
want to push our policy
in a in a small amount so the question
now is how do we take that philosophy of
only updating our policy in a small
amount
and turn it into math and so what ppo
does is it's going to solve this and i'm
going to try to walk you through how it
does it so
the first thing that we can do is take a
ratio of our new policy versus our old
policy that's going to give us
r and these are probabilities so we can
take uh kind of the division of them
now
r again is just going to be a measure
we need to have an understanding of
whether this is good or bad and so again
we just bring in our advantage function
to to tell us that
so we can map out r and so ours because
it's probabilities your lowest value is
going to be zero and it's going to go up
to some amount
i'm going to put one here that one's
kind of special because that just means
that your new policy is the same as your
old policy
so
your advantage function again is just
going to be some scalar some
amount and so a positive scalar times
this kind of growing r you should expect
kind of this linear line
and so
this is for
events that are good so to just break
this down a little bit more it's saying
that
you know we have this ratio and
in the last kind of
iteration our vantage function said that
we did better than we expected
so if we do better than we expected then
we want to take those actions more often
so we want to increase the probabilities
of those
actions and so we want to increase uh
our policy and so this dot just says
given some sort of r
we're going to want to push that r up
and update
so the next time we come around our
policy is being pushed in the upward
direction
now we'll just do the same for if the
advantage function is negative meaning
that we have done uh worse than we
expected
and so again that's just some negative
number we're just multiplying that by a
growing r so we get this negative kind
of linear line
and then again if we have a point it's
important to remember that we're going
in the up direction
now the problem here
is if r is big or if r is small so let's
say r is big it means that our new
policy has higher probabilities of
taking certain actions
so as a result we might move too far in
that direction
and so really what ppo is doing is it's
clamping at a certain point
saying that at some point
of r value we're not going to push kind
of it any higher than it should be
and then for the negative side we're
also going to do the same so we're
clamping it at some sort of negative
now oftentimes
this is represented so this little box
that i drew around
the width of that box is 2 epsilon and
so the epsilon value that's used in
practice is usually 0.2
but what's also really nice about this
kind of negative one is that
you're able to kind of undo
sort of the policy that you just have
because you're pushing it back to one
which is closer to the old policy that
you
had initially
so unity's in the title so now now's
unity's turn so uh ppo uh which is the
algorithm that we just talked about is
one of the options that's in this kind
of ml agents kind of uh
work and what's great about this is you
don't need to implement this you just
type in ppo in your config file along
with some hyper parameters
there are a lot of hyper parameters here
so that epsilon that i talked about is a
hyper parameter i'm not going to have
time to talk about how to how to tune
that
underlying unity ml is pi torch so if
you're familiar with that framework
that's kind of what's running the whole
thing
unity is kind of wrapping up what's uh
often called a gym so openai has a gym
kind of framework that allows you to
create environments unity is just
allowing you to do that directly in
unity itself and then the last thing
that i want to mention is that unity is
using barracuda inference engine so this
is their inference engine
inference for those who are not familiar
is just how you take your trained model
and actually deploy it and and use it
and the file format that they use is
onyx which is an open neural network
exchange format
and you can just
it will read those files so you can do
more than just rl you can do supervised
learning in
unity if you want so image
object detection image classification
so
how does that map to unity so unity has
a number of functions that you just over
override so one of them is on episode
begin so that just sets up your agent
your environment you have collect
observations so that's just mapping your
environment to a specific state
and then you have on action received
which is going to allow you to determine
how much rewards you want to give for a
certain action and then what action you
should take
and i'll show you
and then the policy which we just talked
about you just set in the in the config
file
so uh
code example so here's a very simple
problem somewhat analogous to what we're
doing is uh we have a ball and we just
want it to hit a box um it's kind of in
there kind of getting up and running
with unity and ml so
the kind of on episode begin is just
initializing where that ball placement
is and where the box is
and then collect observations is really
saying you have sort of a vector of
numbers and you can just add numbers to
that vector so that's mapping
the state
and then on action received allows you
to read from another buffer
this buffer is called action buffers and
then you describe uh you know what each
of those values means in this problem
it's going to be the forces in the x and
because unity uh is in a different
coordinate system than than others the z
which will be to the kind of horizontal
plane
and then if you have kind of your in
state then you can set a reward
so now we're gonna detour
okay so uh this is rudolph coleman
uh he was a hungarian electrical
engineer uh born in uh budapest
and uh his work
is famous for um also being a part of
the apollo program
because uh his work was found by stanley
schmidt who saw what he was doing and
thought this would be great to include
in the kind of control systems uh for
the rockets
so coleman
commons goal really is to know where
this rocket is in space
and there ideally that rocket is where
you want it to be in space but there are
really kind of two methods that you have
access to the first one is you have your
equations
you apply them but you'll know that
they're very sensitive to initial
conditions so you'll get drift over time
so what you also have is a very
expensive sensor
that will kind of inform you to the best
of its abilities kind of where it thinks
its rocket is so so coleman's
uh goal is given those two things i have
sort of how my system moves
through some equations and then i also
have access to a sensor how best to
combine those two pieces of information
to have the best representation of my
state so that's the problem
and i'll walk you through how you can
kind of
get to a pretty close formulation of how
this works so we have system a and then
we have our sensor b and we want to get
to c
so let's start with a super simple
example our sensor is is perfect there's
zero error so uh in this case
what we want to do is put all of our
trust in our sensor and so the best that
we can do is say that c eventually is
going to just be b
um now i'm going to write it in this
kind of odd format but the way i like to
think of it is that we have some sort of
position a
and we need to know how much we need to
move a
to get it to where b is and so by taking
the difference of b minus a we're we
know how much to move
but again you can just cancel out the
a's and you get c
now if we take the flip side of that
where now uh our system
uh is perfect and uh we have some error
on our sensor we don't care about then
we can just trust all of our system
so if we take that last equation that we
had
what can we add to it
to kind of get it to where it finally
equals c equals a and so
we can just multiply that by zero
does the trick so now we kind of have a
system of equations we have sort of this
formula and we have kind of two states
when m is zero
x equals zero
and when m is one we know that y equals
zero so we need some equation that takes
x and y and returns those m amounts at
when
x and y equal those amounts so
to get m equals 1 when y is 0
we can
do that so we just take x over x that
will return one we just now need to know
where we put y so we know y is zero in
this case so we can just add it to the
bottom and then we need to check to make
sure that the fact is that when x equals
zero we do actually have
m the whole equation itself equals zero
so if x is zero then
zero on the numerator and then y is some
sort of amount so
it becomes zero
so i'm going to change m to k
and now k is kind of described in that
fashion and k is called the coleman gain
so it's the optimal way to kind of weigh
those two systems given that you know
sort of error in between those two
and then you use c to be your new state
name and you just kind of run this in an
iteration
um
kind of glancing over some stuff but uh
when we take this actually and we bump
it up to matrix operations of course it
looks a little bit more um complicated
but really it's this sort of same
component so what i'm highlighting now
is
sort of this system error plus the
sensor error component
so r is the covariance of the
observation noise i'm just calling that
sensor error and then
sort of p of k is kind of the the noise
in your your system
now h's are what's called observation
matrixes and that just collapses some
parts of your system if you don't have
sensors for them so you don't always
have sensors to to measure your
acceleration and your velocity you may
only have position and so h kind of
collapses those components that you
don't want to match so you're matching
apples to apples
and then this last part the common gain
is really just the system error divided
by this sk term that we just found as
the system error plus the sensor error
and because you don't have division in
matrix operations you of course takes
the the inverse and so you kind of put
them together and h is there again just
to knock off the terms that you don't
have
so
i'm going to now
show this uh
in in a demo
and it's a lot more fun to actually see
this work
so
okay
all right there we go so uh double
pendulums are really great to to model
because they are so chaotic
and so what you're seeing is this little
blue dot is representing a sensor going
off the sensor rate is 100 frames so
every 100 frames you're getting a sensor
go off and it's just recording its
position so
there are a number of things here but
the reason that double pendulums are
great is because they're so sensitive to
initial condition and so there are
actually two pendulums that were there
to begin with and so we can imagine for
the purpose of this demonstration that
the blue pendulum is the real world we
don't have access to it and but what we
do have is a good model of the real
world and that's the gray and so what we
want to do is use the kalman filter
to actually get this to link on by
taking
information from that sensor that the
real world is kind of
sporadically
taking off so what we're going to do is
now we're going to have the coleman gain
on
and we're taking that sensor reading and
what you'll see is the gray kind of
diverges but then it snaps back on every
time it takes a sensor reading and so we
have some initial error which is higher
than the last case and then we have some
sensor error and so now what you'll also
see
is this also kind of just jumps off and
the
reason being is that again this is
highly non-linear system and very very
sensitive
so what you do in this case is what we
can do is we're going to decrease
or
give sensor readings more often and so
by taking sensor readings say
every 17 frames we can lock on really
quickly
because we're taking so many readings
and so you can adjust this of course you
know to
take sensor readings every 30 frames or
so and you'll get more drift in between
those those readings you can then also
of course increase how much error is in
your sensor so you know our sensor now
is pretty noisy and you can kind of
notice that the blue is kind of jumping
around and not on any of the paths
and so and the kind of
visual at the bottom just represents how
far they're diverging now
when you do calm and gain stuff you'll
also
hit
what's called the ensemble common gain
an ensemble just meaning a lot a number
uh of of these models so what you do in
practice is you actually run
multiple of them um of these models and
so now right now we're running 10
and what you'll see is what we could do
is we take the average so now the
average is in red and we'll find that
that red tracks a lot better
than just doing one of them specifically
the last thing i'll do is i'm going to
really
bump up the ensemble count so my frame
rate will die but uh what you'll see
you can barely see it really is that the
red is tracking really well on that um
kind of uh real world the blue even
though our are you know uh we have noise
in our sensors so ensemble kalman filter
seen kind of an action the other term
that you'll hit too is extended kalman
filter and i don't have a demonstration
of that because we can decrease the
sensor right here but extended just
means you take into the fact that you're
dealing with a non-linear system and so
you need to take the jacobian of your
kind of transition matrix and that gives
you a better representation of doing
this but the same principle is there how
best to kind of take your sensor data
and some equation of state
okay so back to the presentation
all right so why did i tell you that
so uh
the the
coleman gain
um because it's kind of um trying to
minimize the error between two source uh
data might actually make a really good
method for calculating reward when you
have data to use and so this paper
called a statistical similarity measure
for aggregate crowd dynamics
was kind of the first to push for this
idea of using the kalman filter
as a way to measure how well
data and simulation match
so let's get back on track so this is a
video of kind of the work that we did so
first you need data so this is data from
immutable crowds uh a paper morphable
crowds and what really the data is is
this is just a point uh time position
history so from that time position from
history you get trajectories and each
agent has a kind of time position
history and so we have that data then
what we'll do is we'll construct a
similar world
in kind of unity
and we'll assign
our training agent one of those paths
and we'll also then simulate all the
other agents that are around during that
time
so this is of course sped up the black
lines that you see out of the agent
that's learning so the agent that's
learning right now is kind of fumbling
around because it's still early in the
training and they're up at the top
in white and then the agents that kind
of reach their destination immediately
are the ones from the data itself so the
black lines are
mimicking or visualizing sight and so
that's just taking kind of positions of
of all the objects in its in its view
and
so
as this kind of training goes on we
start to see this agent better reach its
terminal position so that terminal
position is is marked in green and uh
that's kind of what the data is
suggesting the terminal position to be
and what's really i think important here
is that the only reward that we're using
is this sort of this this uh
this entropy based equation
that has no
additional reward for reaching your kind
of trajectory
so it's a very hands-off kind of
approach really once we had this reward
metric what we were really focused in on
is giving the agent the right amount of
information so it can better learn kind
of this environment so this is final
result and so
i'll also kind of have a very quick
demonstration of this as well but we see
that this agent sort of is able to
navigate around
objects and has some understanding of
kind of not trying to
totally hit into someone but again the
the data that we're working on too i
think it's important to to mention is
it's really only about
20 to 30 trajectories so not a lot of
data but we're still able to get an
agent that performs somewhat uh
characteristic so
to see kind of the graphs of what
happens so if you're ever training and
you see a graph like this this is not
good
ideally you want this this kind of graph
to go up much more and so up is good and
then
the kind of horizontal axis is over kind
of the entire
training process and so we're training
over a million steps
and on this computer it takes about
seven hours to give you a sense
so the reason that one's not so great is
that we gave the agent no sight so the
agent really doesn't understand anything
around it we just give the agent kind of
its final trajectory and
kind of where it is in space
but no sight
this is a better looking graph and this
is when we have sight
so those black lines that you saw in
that video that represent sight
now one question you might have is what
if we just keep increasing sites so
let's say we had sort of 40 lines
representing and we just double it to
80.
we don't do much better so there is some
sort of limit of course that
just
giving your agent
so much information may not actually be
beneficial
so
reducing that information that you give
to your agent actually
allows it to learn a lot faster and so
what this new line kind of represents is
when you look at all the information
that you're giving your agent and
reducing it down to only giving it kind
of key
parts so really this could just be
reducing kind of one dimension so does
the agent really need to know horizontal
or
altitude information so that could be
something like an example and then the
last thing
the kind of best graph is when you do
data augmentation so super simple one
is you just rotate your kind of platform
and that gives you a lot more data to
work with
and then the last thing is curriculum
learning so the idea being
that you want to first train your agent
on maybe 10 trajectories and then you
give them 15 and then you finally give
them 20. and so that way it's able to
kind of generalize
over a larger set by still being able to
kind of capture key things it needs to
know over a smaller one
so the the reason that this is pretty
fascinating is once you have an agent
that's trained
you can take that agent and put them in
environments that they never have seen
before
and that the data themselves never had
had so
all right let's see if this
works
okay so this is a very simple
demonstration and again these agents
were only trained over 20 trajectories
the trajectories were only about
two or three seconds and so what we can
do is then just spawn a bunch of them
and
you know have them kind of all kind of
grasp towards a specific point
and so you might see some some
applicability here one for entertainment
but also one for being able to quantify
certain kind of characteristics and so
we can kind of restart that and see how
they all kind of drift towards that sort
of point again they're not getting any
specific reward for reaching their
destination so they don't really
have that like desire to like always hit
that end point
they more so just want to capture the
overall behavior and that's what that uh
kind of entropy metric does
so um
okay so to close up
this presentation
uh so closing thoughts so so why is this
kind of cool i think
the
agents will be able to generalize the
behavior from their data set so the the
kind of data that we grabbed was
interesting because
each data set had a characteristic a
human emotion attached to it so there
was one that was more
of kind of a shy movement across that
corridor and there was one that was more
aggressive and so you can take those
kind of
behaviors
try to boil them and generalize them
into an agent and then you could see how
they interact between each other
i'm sure there are other use cases
so what i'm looking for more and i'm
sure a lot of people of course always
like is more data sets to do this
and then what would be really
fascinating is if you can close the
pipeline so that you have some sort of
camera feed that's able to capture
trajectories and then use that
immediately as data to capture
and that would allow you to construct
agents for different types of spaces
that you can then deploy
so thank you i hope i i
taught you guys everything and then
here's my contact information
[Applause]
[Music]
you